I don't think there's been this much
hype for a galaxy phone in at least a
few years there is at least 15 people
lined up at Best Buy and they only had
one unlock unit which is the one that I
got so obviously there's a lot of hype
around these new s10 and SN Plus phones
if you're into reading the comments
there's a lot of iPhone users that are
contemplating switching to these new
Galaxy phones and personally this is the
most excited I've been about a galaxy
phone in years let's go in and unbox
this s10 plus and I'll give you guys my
honest comparison from an iPhone users
perspective all right so let's peel off
the sticker here this thing feels really
really light in the hand
size-wise if you look it's very similar
to the iPhone 10's max a little bit
slimmer probably because of these curved
edges here but weight wise man that is a
really big difference and I do have to
mention that this has a much larger
battery 4100 milliamp hour compared to
just over 3100 the power button if you
guys could see right there it's much
higher so if I'm holding this in my hand
comfortably I'm not hitting this whereas
with the iPhone I guess I don't touch
the whole thing but it definitely is
clickable and usable holding these
side-by-side you could definitely tell
that the s10 plus has thinner bezels on
the top on the sides they're much
thinner because that curved screen and
then on the bottom as far as the chin
the s10 pluses is just slightly thicker
than the bezel on the iPhone 10s max and
now to scan the fingerprint now I will
be switching over from the 10s max to
the s10 plus for at least a week and
doing a follow-up video showing you guys
all of the differences all of my
observations being a long time Apple an
iPhone user and then switching over to
the Samsung so if you guys want to check
out the video make sure you hit that
subscribe button and enable those
notifications now since we set up the
ultrasonic sensor I do want to compare
kind of like the speeds with the iPhone
you have to touch and then swipe up for
face idea where the Samsung you should
be able to just press well very
interesting let's try that again
no match interesting it's hard to do
both but let's do a couple separately so
that one's pretty quick but you do
notice that a delay so it's definitely
some delay but all you have to do is put
your finger down on the screen you'll
have to do two steps or anything like
that no match again if you guys bought
an s10 or sn+ let me know how you like
the fingerprint scanner and how often it
just doesn't work for you so now let's
compare to display quality the first
thing that I have to do is go into the
display settings and change the
resolution to the highest I can't really
see any difference in sharpness the
screen on the tennis max is already
really good and the Samsung one looks
really good as well so I'm on Google's
homepage both of our maxed out as far as
brightness I do have a color temperature
difference because of true tone on the
iPhone but the iPhone does look brighter
even though it's rated at 625 nits
compared to up to 1,200 on the s 10 plus
but even what is that as far as our
zebra stripes and the camera which one
looks brighter the iPhone is definitely
brighter in the camera we can see the
different brightness levels there's a
meter built into there maybe this will
get brighter if you're outside in it
senses that you need that extra
brightness now as I'm looking at these
full white screens I could definitely
see the difference in the notch in the
cutout so the iPhone has that notch that
is infamous it's quite large
whereas Samsung opted to you a little
cut out with sm+ featuring a kind of
pill box shape one I would say that the
pill shape cut out is definitely less
intrusive if you don't notice it as much
so I like this design but I do wish a
Samsung included just a single circular
cutout on the s10 plus just like it has
on the s10 and the s10 II the extra
camera inside of the pill box of the s10
plus is for depth sensing to give you
better selfie portrait photos so we're
gonna get out our bokeh tree and let's
take a comparison shot and you guys let
me know which one you think looks nicer
now let's flip back to the rear cameras
we have two on the iPhone and we have
three now on the s10 and s10 plus so
let's take a photo here
with the standard one and I'll show you
guys the ultra wide lens
you see a lot more now let's do a
portrait shot and one interesting thing
is that the Samsung now uses though the
standard lens not the telephoto one for
portrait photos so that's definitely
going to be a preference personally
being a photographer I like having a
longer focal length for my portraits but
you can let us know which one you think
looks better in the comment section
below I also want to mention that we
will be doing full detailed comparisons
both with photos and with videos looking
at quality low wide dynamic range all of
that good stuff so make sure you guys
are subscribed and you have those
notifications enabled so now let's
compare the speaker's now this has been
an area where the Samsung's were always
weaker than the iPhones they're one step
behind they were using the just a bottom
speaker for quite a while I have them
the same distance away from me they're
both firing out and towards me so let's
listen
[Music]
so the s10 plus is definitely louder and
this is a first at least in the last
couple of years the iPhone is not as
loud the heists aren't as piercing I
would say but the lower end the bass is
a little bit more punchy so if you like
volume over kind of a richer sound I
think the Samsung is better and the
iPhone sounds a little bit more balanced
especially for holding it out like this
and listening to it both speakers both
the earpiece speaker and the bottom
speaker they're more even whereas with
the Samsung phone you definitely hear
more sound from the bottom speaker than
the earpiece speaker but it definitely
is loud which is nice if you're in an
environment where there's other noise so
I mentioned that I couldn't tell the
detail difference in the icons and as
far as the brightness the iPhone was
brighter on Google's homepage but now
playing back an HDR video in youtube I
can definitely see a clear difference
the Samsung both gets darker more
contrast II while being more bright at
the same time and here looking at these
blacks the iPhone I never thought I'd
say this actually the blacks look
slightly gray compared to the Samsung
which looks pure black now if you
compare this iPhone to any of the
previous iPhones I mean it's an amazing
display but looking at him like this
the Samsung is definitely a good step
ahead of the iPhone now for our last
comparison the most important one of all
and that is the Geekbench scores of
course I'm kidding about that but I am
curious as far as the single core score
the iPhone is still much higher with
4,800 compared to 3500 but the
multi-core is very close
11500 versus 11,000 so the snapshot
processors are catching up
and that multi-core score is pretty
impressive alright guys so hopefully you
enjoyed our hands-on comparison of the
iPhone tennis max and the new s10 plus I
will be switching over to the s10 plus
for at least a week and then doing a
follow up video on what kind of
differences I saw coming from the iPhone
so if you want to check that out make
sure you have those notifications
enabled this has been max with max tech
and I'll see you in the next video